en una clase de idiomas la razón de
niñas de niñas a niños es 5 a 8 si hay
65 estudiantes cuántas niñas hay a esto
está interesante nos dan la razón de
niñas a niños pero nos piden determinar
la cantidad de niñas sabiendo el número
total de estudiantes entonces más que la
razón de niñas a niños la razón que nos
interesa es la de niñas me voy a poner
aquí niñas a número total de estudiantes
entonces aquí le voy a poner estudiantes
estudiantes ok y cómo le hacemos para
calcular esta razón bueno pues la razón
de niñas a niños es una muy buena pista
nos dice que por cada cinco niñas hay
ocho niños entonces por cada cinco niñas
en total están esas cinco niñas y estos
ocho niños o sea en total hay 13
estudiantes y esto lo podemos pensar de
la siguiente manera lo podemos pensar
como que si el grupo lo dividimos en
grupos de 13 estudiantes entonces cada
uno de esos grupos si todo está
repartido equitativamente tendrá cinco
niñas vale bueno pero ahora lo que nos
piden es encontrar la cantidad
y ya tenemos esta razón ya debe ser
fácil calcularlo entonces cómo le
hacemos pues vemos cuántos grupos de 13
estudiantes caben aquí en 65 estudiantes
vamos a ponerle aquí que en total son 65
estudiantes y notemos que hay cinco
grupos de 13 en 65 vale entonces aquí
multiplicamos por 5 bueno cada uno de
esos cada uno de esos grupos de 13 va a
tener 5 niñas entonces hay que
multiplicar esto por 5 y por lo tanto en
total serían 25 niñas entonces esta
razón de aquí nos dice que en un grupo
con 65 estudiantes hay 25 niñas dada la
información del problema